there's there's a pending rule
potentially to the overtime procedures
it's been tabled until may clark hunt
the owner of the chiefs the team that
put forward the proposal that would
guarantee a second possession even if
the team that gets the first possession
over time scores a touchdown he's
optimistic that in may they will
allow this procedure to be changed and
he thinks it may happen only for the
postseason but regardless of when it
would apply
what do you do well and i think there is
a fundamental difference between regular
season and postseason on this do you
choose to kick off if you are the team
that wins the toss knowing you are
guaranteed a second possession no matter
what and chris i think whether it's
regular season or postseason is a big
factor in how you resolve that that
dilemma well i i'll say this i do think
that the kickoff will be the way nfl
coaches decide to go i think they're
going to elect to kick the ball one
because it's something you've said about
the college rule so many times right
where you know they're going to want to
see what they got to do as far as when
they get the ball do i gotta match a
touchdown is it a field goal whatever it
may be
but the big reason i think that teams
will elect a kick now the fact that they
know they're going to get the ball too
it's going to allow the defense to maybe
play it a little more aggressively than
they normally would
in the way we've had it the last few
years you're not going to be as you know
i feel like the last two years a lot of
teams just go gosh you know let's just
not give up a big play
let's play kind of conservative and make
them earn the touchdown and a lot of the
times we see with the way quarterbacks
and uh receivers catch and throw the
ball this day and age they go down and
score a touchdown now i think knowing
that you're going to get a chance to get
the ball back i think a defensive
quarter might go defensive coordinator
is going to be a little more inclined to
go you know what i was scared to call
this with the old overtime rules but now
i know
patrick mahomes is going to get a chance
i might bring the the corn you know the
free safety weak side linebacker blitz
in this situation and go for it and see
if i can stop the drive right here on a
third and five or whatever it may be i
think it gives the defensive coordinator
a little bit more power uh and not not
necessarily so afraid to blow the game
you know with one aggressive maybe take
a chance type call on the defensive side
yeah look here's where i think the the
decision becomes more challenging in the
regular season because there's only 10
minutes available for overtime if you
choose to kick the ball off and they
drive down the field and score a
touchdown how much time are you going to
have to match it sure if they take six
seven eight minutes you're going to
really be pinched to try to play for a
tie i'd almost rather take the ball
especially if i'm at home well at home
but you know what i'm at home i'm more
likely to kick i think well in the
regular school what you're saying right
there and you just kind of led me into
it you know intentionally again
i think because of what you said you're
worried about that team you know eating
up too much of the clock again since you
know you're gonna get the ball back at
some point i think defenses will take a
chance and go okay they're they're kind
of like bleeding us to death here little
by little let's take a trance and see if
we can get the big sack or try to force
a tuner turnover or whatever it is
either they score okay whatever it be if
they score they score and then at least
we get the ball back with some time to
go down and get a touchdown ourselves uh
but maybe we can make something happen
to where they got a punt or settle for a
long field goal or something like that
if i'm at home in a loud stadium in the
regular season i'm going to be more
inclined to kick if i'm on the road and
i win that toss
i'm pr i don't know what i'm going to do
at that point it's going to depend on a
lot of factors in the postseason though
i'm more likely to kick
because i'm not constrained by the
amount of time right right
it's a 15 minute overtime but you're
still guaranteed to complete your
possession i you know these are things
we've never really discussed it has
never gotten to this point but i i i
still think that if you haven't had a
chance to finish your possession you
still get to go beyond that 15 minutes
until you get your possession so if
you're guaranteed that possession and
the first team has taken 13 minutes and
you take 13 minutes then it's a 26
minute overtime in the post season but
the other thing is this you will know
exactly what you have to do when you
have the ball right you you may only
need a field goal yeah and you have a
walk-off winner right or if you want to
go for two you know we talked about this
with andy reid earlier in the week when
you raised the possibility of well then
they'll say it's unfair if both teams
score a touchdown and then the team that
had the original kickoff gets it again
and it's sudden death and that's not
fair and well maybe it won't happen
because maybe that team will go for two
if they get the chance to to score the
touchdown and then go for the walk-off
winner and end it all there but i i
think postseason i'm more likely to kick
off regular season it's going to depend
on other factors because there's only 10
minutes to work with and i may end up
not having enough time if i get too cute
with it and choose to kick off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports